à dijon le procès de jean marie villemin
se poursuit le verdict devrait être
prononcé le 15 décembre
cet après midi la cour d'assises entendu
un témoignage troublant est plutôt
accablant pour bernard laroche
compte rendu d'audience dominique
verdeilhan gilles dollars pour charlotte
conrôle affaire grégory ce fut d'abord
un fait divers qui elle suivait dans les
journaux mais sa curiosité l'a fait
devenir témoin fin 85 avec son mari elle
a acheté le pavillon des villemin à
lépanges sur vologne
j'étais curieuse on est allé sur la
tombe de grégory puis voir la maison
plus tard on l'a acheté pour la vue
monsieur le président elles étaient 86
elle reçoit des confidences de sa
voisine madame claudon elle m'a dit que
le 16 octobre vers 17 heures en
compagnie d'un ami elle avait croisé en
voiture bernard laroche quelqu'un était
à ses côtés
j'ai insisté pour qu'elle le dise à la
justice elle m'a répondu je ne peux pas
parce que le monsieur avec qui j'étais
aurait dû être à ce moment là à son
travail
une confidence qu'elle gardera pour elle
jusqu en octobre 90 à cette époque elle
se confiera à m e moser son conseil qui
est aussi celui de jean marie villemin
madame claude on a toujours nié les
faits en revanche son amie les a
reconnus ils seront entendus par la cour
d'assises
je dis aujourd'hui madame conraux
regrette l'acquisition de son pavillon
car dit elle elle est embêté par les
curieux et par les journalistes certes
la faire là un moment passionné mais
elle reconnaît aujourd'hui ô combien
cette confidence troublante est tardive
à quelque chose de compromettant surtout
émanant de quelqu'un étrangers aux deux
familles